the latest on a surge in covet cases
alongside a new push to get booster
shots at least 42 states have seen
hospitalizations go up over the past
week
and almost exclusively due to
unvaccinated people catching delta
variant the number of new cases has
jumped nearly 16 nationwide nikki
batiste is in wilkes-barre pennsylvania
where cases are on the rise
there's a lot of hoops to jump through
just
to fight for your life caitlyn lilly's
brother kyle whiting was unvaccinated
when he contracted kovid in october he's
been hospitalized ever since
do you think that had kyle been
vaccinated he'd be in a different
position today i think it would have
helped him medically i think it wouldn't
have been as bad but i couldn't say for
sure if it would have prevented all this
so far whiting has spent his 27th
birthday on life support and has even
missed his wedding his lungs are no
longer functioning and he now needs a
double transplant an operation that was
delayed by a week as he waited for an
open bed in a philadelphia hospital he's
never going to have the same life he had
nationwide cases are increasing
overwhelming many hospitals geisinger
wyoming valley medical center in
wilkes-barre is operating at about 120
percent capacity with nearly a quarter
of patients in the covid unit it feels
like the outside world has
sort of said well the pandemic is behind
us and then i go to work and it's very
much not emergency room physician dr
essie reed says most of the patients she
sees are unvaccinated the saddest thing
is when they're asking when they can get
the vaccine
and you're just not sure if they're
going to make it to that point
kyle whiting was perfectly healthy and
had no underlying conditions when he got
coveted he's now going through several
evaluations and tests that won't have to
be vaccinated before his transplant his
fiancee who was unvaccinated before is
now fully vaccinated gail
well that's good news it's another
cautionary tale thank you very much
nikki